joyeux anniversaire c'est un premier
amour qui dure
je trouve ça fou on a une super vie
sexuelle havre ouais la télécommande
comparé à quoi le parfait petit couple
si prévisible et ennuyeux à mourir
c'est pas comme si je passais à côté de
quelque chose je sais à quel point tu
m'aimes ce que je veux dire c'est que tu
peux compter avec d'autres femmes
comment on appellerait ça je sais pas
moi du libertinage ne peut pas on est un
vrai coup non tu peux juste sauté
d'autres fina et tu pourrais faire la
même chose évidemment c'est ce que tu
veux tu es sur wii moi c'est dan aux
moines
tu veux danser
il est plutôt sympa et puis il plaît
tant à son goût nos études bigorre
quatre morts
bonjour je suis venue acheter cette
table je suis chez moi ce soir au bon
soir tu as la même hauteur que mon père
je suis furieux et si tu vas mois sata
puis au bout d'un moment dans donc ça a
duré un long moment
et vous avez fait la totale en partie
oui je pense que tu devrais la revoir et
toi tu vas le recevoir
oui
hu
[Musique]
ça marche encore au lit
oui
[Musique]
on se connaît pas
je sais que je te fais du bien qui tu
étais un film c'est ce que j'éprouve un
mais on n'est pas la plupart du temps
j'en chie
non survie
quand t'es pas à côté de moi je sais
plus qui suis tu
savoir qui tu es permission le 1er mars
en icinéma sur le service de vidéo à la
demande
exclusivement chez vous